hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory
excuse the voice I'm sick right now but
I'll do my best today we're going to be
discussing Hogwarts Legacy the much
anticipated Harry Potter game that's
hitting shelves in just over a week
specifically we're going to be taking a
look at all major Heroes professors and
villains from the game describing who
they are what we know about them and
from my own curiosity how they might fit
into the existing Harry Potter Canon
let's get into it the villains kicking
things off with a bang let me introduce
you to the antagonists of Hogwarts
Legacy ranrock in Hogwarts Legacy
ranrock is a goblin who serves as the
main antagonist plotting to rebel
against the ministry of magic although
Goblin rebellions have previously
occurred in the Harry Potter universe
ranrock is a new and original character
created specifically for this game
ranrock was a greedy Goblin driven by
the desire to obtain a magical power
that was kept hidden even from the
wizard Community his hatred for all
wizards and witches distorted his
worldview and led him to seek their
destruction the goal of the game is to
thwart ranrock's Rebellion however
despite his hatred ranrock ended up
forming a tenuous alliance with a group
of dark Wizards led by Victor Rookwood
one of the ancestors of Death Eater and
unspeakable Augustus Rookwood Victor
Rookwood Victor Rookwood the other main
antagonist was a dark wizard who was
known for his shabby albeit Dapper
looking clothing from a very young age
Victor was taught to bend the rules when
possible and break them when necessary
at the age of 22 he took over his
father's criminal organization after his
father's sudden and suspicious death he
quickly expanded the business launching
it to become one of the most successful
gangs in the area other thieves and
poachers saw the benefits of joining
forces with Victor and his gang but he
eventually gained control over these
Partnerships and grew his power to
include an extortion operation Victor
aimed to become the most notorious
criminal in Europe directing his gang to
victimize hogsmead's Residents in nearby
Villages by robbing Travelers smuggling
rare magical creatures and extorting
hogsmead's shopkeepers for protection
money in the game Victor commands a
group of dark human Wizards and through
his partnership with ran Rock helps
immobilize forces for the Rebellion the
only unknown at least for now is why
he's doing that why would Rookwood help
branrock I guess time will tell
professors next up we've got the
professors who as we know from existing
Harry Potter Canon have a significant
impact on the lives of Hogwarts students
without the professors it's certainly
not Hogwarts so let me introduce you to
some names you may have never heard of
at least the ones that we know about so
far Professor Dinah Heckert was a witch
who taught defense against the dark arts
at Hogwarts school during the late 19th
century she was known for being strict
but also likable taking her teaching
duties seriously her approach to
teaching was considered to be Hands-On
and and was said to satisfy a natural
desire for Action in her classroom she
had a hybridian black skeleton hanging
from the roof which she obtained as a
trophy from the great poacher raid of
1878 where she single-handedly took down
the largest poaching ring in eastern
Wales before working at Hogwarts Hackett
had a successful career the ministry of
magic working as an unspeakable in the
department of mysteries Professor
Eleazar fig was a wizard who taught
magical Theory at Hogwarts school during
the late 19th century he was known for
being kind and knowledgeable and was
sorted into Gryffindor House during his
own time at Hogwarts he initially
pursued a career the ministry of magic
but abandoned this ambition to join his
wife Miriam on her travels and Research
into ancient Egypt Eleazar eventually
settled into a teaching career at
Hogwarts where he became known as an
accomplished and enigmatic figure during
the 1890 to 1891 school year a new
student with an unusual ability to
detect and harness ancient magic Corp
Professor Fig's attention us after
investigating our characters ancient
bloodline he begins to further
investigate rumors surrounding ran Rock
and the impending Goblin Rebellion
Professor Abraham Ronan was a wizard who
taught charms at Hogwarts School in the
late 19th century he had a friendly
personality with a mischievous twinkle
in his eye and placed equal importance
in the students friendships and
extracurricular activities as he did on
the subject of charms as the school's
charms Master Professor Ronan was given
classroom 2E on the third floor and an
office he taught in an unconventional
way incorporating gameplay into his
lessons and creating a summoner's court
for students to practice the summoning
charm in the
1890-1891 school year when we start
Professor Ronan is still the charms
master and ends up holding remedial
classes for us due to the fact that we
started at Hogwarts as a fifth year
Professor Mirabel garlic was a witch who
talked herbology at Hogwarts school
during the late 19th century she was
muggable had a kind and caring
personality with a sunny disposition she
referred to her students affectionately
as roses and was highly regarded by both
her colleagues and students Maribel was
sorted into Hufflepuff during her own
time as a student at Hogwarts her
passion for herbology and Charming
personality made her a popular Professor
causing some students to worry that she
might leave them for another Greenhouse
Professor mudawa unai was an African
witch who taught the subject of
divination at Hogwarts school during the
late 19th century she was the mother of
a Gryffindor student named natsai onai
who was transferred to Hogwarts from
wagadu after Professor onai's
appointment as the professor of
divination Professor onai was strict and
had high expectations for her students
and daughter she had a commanding
presence in every room she entered and
demanded respect from everyone she
interacted with previously Professor
onai taught divination at regardo and
was a gifted Seer however her faith was
shaken when she did not foresee the
death of her own husband to escape those
painful memories she accepted an
invitation from Professor Weasley to
teach at Hogwarts esip sharp was a
wizard who worked as an aura for the
British Ministry of magic and later as a
potions Master at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and was a dream he was born
into a Wizarding family attended
Hogwarts school and was eventually
sorted into Slytherin house after being
ambushed and injured during an aura
assignment he retired and became a
potions Master at Hogwarts he was known
for his Gruff and acute nature
challenging lessons and pride in
students who excelled in his class
unsurprisingly he teaches at the school
during the 1890 to 1891 school year and
encounters a new student with unusual
abilities us Professor satyavati Shah
was the astronomy professor at Hogwarts
School in the late 19th century raised
in the Muggle World Sean developed an
interest in science which he carried
into her studies at Hogwarts where she
was sorted into Raven house after
graduation she became the astronomy
professor and was very dedicated to her
subject often appearing cold and
demanding she had little regard for
other Hogwarts disciplines viewing them
as wishy-washy especially divination and
now a few familiar names Cuthbert bins
Professor bins AKA Cuthbert bins is the
history of magic professor at Hogwarts
he taught in classroom 4f on the first
floor and he continued to teach their
post-morsum Bin's lessons were
considered to be some of the most boring
at Hogwarts and he made no effort to
learn his students names calling
Hermione Miss Grant and Harry Potter
Perkins bin slept in front of the fire
in the Hogwarts staff room one night and
died in his sleep the next morning he
left his body behind and got up to teach
as if nothing had happened it stated
that the most exciting thing to ever
happen in his class was when he entered
the room through the Blackboard given
that Benz is already a ghost in Harry
Potter it makes sense that he'd be
around in Hogwarts Legacy nigellus black
Phineas nigellus black of the infamous
House of black was born in 1847 and
became one of the most influential
members of the family to ever live as
most blacks would Phineas attended
Hogwarts and once of course placed into
house Southern Phineas was also very
vocal in carrying on another family
tradition his hatred for Muggles and
mudbloods later in life Phineas became a
professional teacher passing on all that
he'd learned to the next generation of
witches and wizards his talents
eventually brought him to Hogwarts but
it's hard to know how effective he was
as a teacher when it comes to Black's
teaching style the record book simply
point out that he hated his job and he
hated the children that didn't stop him
from achieving success though as he
eventually Rose to the possession of
Headmaster Phineas nigella's black went
down in history as one of the least
liked Headmasters that Hogwarts ever had
at least according to his
great-great-grandson Sirius and guess
what he's the Headmaster in Hogwarts
Legacy with all the professors and
villains out of the way let's start
taking a look at our heroes the most
important hero of course is us a fifth
year student who's starting school at
Hogwarts much later than normal the
story centers around our character
possessing an ancient secret that
threatens to tear the Wizarding World
apart the reason for this being that our
character stems from an ancient
bloodline which results in us being one
of the only living Wizards who are
capable of wielding a darker older form
of magic our character will learn about
this bloodline in the first part of the
game and then we will decide whether to
wield or reject it in the second part
which would you choose but of course no
game hero is complete without their
companions alongside Us in this game we
will be paired with one of three the
companion for Slytherin is Sebastian
Salo a Slytherin student whose family
carries a troubling secret the companion
for Gryffindor is natsai onai whose
mother brought her over from ugadu upon
accepting the post as Hogwarts
divination professor and the companion
for Hufflepuff is poppy Sweeting a
kind-hearted character who loved all
manner of magical beasts and despised
poachers it's worth noting that you can
only party up with one of these
companions at a time but that by
spending time with each one we'll have
the opportunity to engage with their own
stories goals and quests and that's it
for this video I'm sure that as time
goes on this list will grow but this is
what we've got for now what video do you
want next I can't wait to cover more
Hogwarts Legacy as time progresses until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]